lorsqu'ils se sont lancés dans le projet
cigognes il y a deux ans est étudiant en
génie mécanique tenait à développer un
produit qui est un réel impact
humanitaire
quand on a rencontré des intervenants de
la croix rouge nous ont dit le transport
des vaccins c'est vraiment une
problématique en ce moment parce qu'on a
des pertes de vaccin parce qu'il ya des
régions difficiles d'accès ça touche
énormément de personnes à bord on parle
en millions de personnes qui ont soit et
démons précoce et des gros problèmes de
santé juste parce qu'ils soient folie
vaccins en bonne qualité
les routes sont détruites il y avait
dans une région éloignée en haut d'une
montagne où il faut y aller à pied donc
quand y arriver avec les vaccins mais
souvent ils sont même plus bon tation
réchauffer en fils les futurs ingénieurs
n'ont pas compté les heures passées à
perfectionner ce drone mais surtout ce
compartiment
spécialement conçu pour le transport de
vaccins une coquille paix à l'intérieur
un compartiment erik gerits puis
réfrigérante de 8 degrés celsius c'est
ça permet de transporter des vaccins
elle dans les conditions et les plus
chaudes qui aura 43 degrés en fait c'est
la température à laquelle il faut tester
pour que ce soit prouvée après de
nombreux calculs tests en laboratoire et
à l'extérieur l'équipe se dit
aujourd'hui
mission accomplie c'est vraiment un
système de réfrigération qui est ultra
légers elles sont gardées les
technologies actuelles tant d'énergie
électrique ou mécanique on peut penser à
mettre un compresseur en commun friche
dalle traditionnelle et c'est vraiment
lourd entre autres un drone comme celui
ci promet mme polvé à technologie en soi
est ce qui fait en sorte que nous en
ayant une technologie qui refroidit
autant que les autres on est capable de
transporter jusqu'à 1400 doses qui est
vraiment innovant soif projet cigognes
était au départ un projet de fin
d'études mais il est sur le point de
devenir une entreprise
les prochaines étapes pour justement
faire des tests avec une compagne tron
dans laquelle on me ferais un
partenariat pour ajuster la cac qui
justement à différents types de drones
depuis le valider sur le terrain est
vraiment dans des conditions un peu
extrême ou qui ensuite ont visé pouvoir
commercialiser la technologie
auprès d'organismes et de gouvernement
on a la chance non seulement d'échanger
les villes des jeunes enfants de toutes
sortes de plats sont c'est encore plus
gratifiant le cas seulement avoir
accompli ce point de vue technique le et
pour les membres du groupe leur produit
ne pouvait pas mieux porté son nom si
genk qui porte l'espoir ou le don de la
vie ici marie et landreau serait au
canada à sherbrooke